Organic banana peel, also known as natural Botox.
This is plant based skincare.
1:01 to have you glowing for those holiday parties.
Okay. Using a banana peel on your skin,
it will help to smooth fine lines and wrinkles,
helps to moisturize your skin,
helps to keep your skin plump.
Give your face a good massage.
Protect your neck. Focus on your neck area.
Let that sit on your skin for about 10 minutes.
Use a warm wet towel and wipe your skin.
Leave your skin a little damp.
3 drops of your favourite moisturizer.
This is Nevel Skin Coffee Oil.
The only moisturizer I use.
Helps to plump your skin, hydrate your skin.
Also how I healed my facial eczema.
One of dermatologist could not instant glow oil on my lips.
Ooh, we glowing.
And um, don't forget the cinnamon baby. Okay.